well some people started their holiday
with a nice brunch or maybe an Easter
egg hunt but for many families their
Easter festivities kicked off with a
special celebration at church Victoria
Saha has more tonight
Easter Service destroyed bright and
early for many across the Las Vegas area
and even some tourists who took the time
to celebrate the resurrection of Jesus
Christ
worshipers filling up the pews at
Guardian Angel Cathedral
Bishop George Leo Thomas leading his
congregation in faith and prayer
though it's a Day celebrating New Life
for parishioners there's always a deeper
message behind Easter Sunday you have
that renewal to you because Christ is
risen this is our life on Earth and you
have to look towards our life in heaven
and our soul in heaven and it's it's
really uh it puts you at peace Easter
marking the holiest day of the year for
Christians Easter is a Celebration of
Hope because of their of their location
right off the strip the guardian angel
Cathedral knew they would have a huge
turnout which is why they had three
today that
combines us no matter where we're from
Victoria saw him eight news now